welcome to Blackpool's Broadway hotel
according to its owners each one of its
bedrooms provides maximum comfort and
you can wake up to breakfast in a
mediterranean-style dining room
not according to guests Tony and Jan
Jenkinson who went online to describe
the place as dirty wrong filthy stinking
all run by mites little did they realize
that the hotel would charge an extra 100
pounds to their credit card in return
for the negative review I was absolutely
furious and I said I said I said you
can't do that I said they'll be
reporting it to whoever I can report you
to including the credit card company
trying it money back so slim if that's
the case I'm going to go back on
TripAdvisor and I'm going to leave
another bad review and tell the truth
about this underground he says well do
that he says but we have the credit card
details and we'll just take another
hundred-pound
shouldn't be called Broadway's should be
called Broadmoor at just 36 pounds a
night for bed and breakfast in Tony's
words he wasn't expecting the Ritz but
he says there's no excuse for what he
found Chester drawers
later look there leave a lot to be
desired the bed is like long-buried rice
pudding on the TripAdvisor website
most of the Broadway's reviews were not
complimentary pure filth avoid said one
another read Fawlty Towers it's not at
least that looked clean but the were
more favorable comments such as ideally
located on the seafront well after
approaching the hotel for a comment a
man who said he represented the Broadway
called me inviting Sky News to make an
offer for an exclusive interview we
decided to decline but the Broadway has
said that it will abandon its policy of
charging for negative reviews
Trading Standards officers in Blackpool
revealed that the Broadway had come to
their attention before the hotel has
been inspected previously interventions
have occurred around food hygiene issues
and because there is a food hygiene
rating system in place as a result of
the interventions the hotel acted upon
the recommendations and has improved
Tony and Jan say they do still enjoy
staying beside the seaside as long as
it's not at the Broadway Mike McCarthy
Sky News Blackpool